So Jacob is talking to God and God says,
behold,
I am with Jessie and it will keep the
an old places where you go and bring you
again into this land for I won't
leave you until I have done that,
which I have spoken to you of.
And Jacob awakened out of his sleep.
And he said,
surely the Lord is in this place.
And I knew what not.
And he was afraid and said,
how dreadful is this place?
This is none other but the house of
God and this is the gate of heaven.
And Jacob Rose up early in the morning
and took the stone that he had put for
his pillows and set it up for a
pillar and poured oil on top of it.
That's a sacrifice.
And he called the name
of that place Bethel.
But the name of the city was
called [inaudible] at the first.
And Jacob vowed a vow saying,
if God will be with me and
we'll keep me in this way,
that I go and will give me bread to eat
and Raymond to put on so that I come
again to my father's house in peace,
then shall the Lord be my God.
And this stone,
which are set for a pillar
shall be God's house.
And of all of that that is given to me,
I will surely give the 10th unto Thee.
And that's a pretty good place to stop.
So now I'll just
conclude.
So you have this very
Morley ambivalent character,
right?
Who's so far,
pretty much everything he's done
that we're familiar with is not good.
So He's,
he's betrayed his brother horribly,
twice,
badly enough so that he,
his brother wants to kill him and
everyone can kind of sympathize with his
brother.
So,
and then he runs away essentially
because his mother tells him too,
which is not exactly a
testament to his character.
And despite that,
strangely enough,
he has this experience,
you know?
And that's heartening,
I guess.
And that's the point is that
people are predisposed to terrible error.
There's no doubt about that.
And yet
when I was writing my latest book,
I had a friend of mine,
Norman Doidge wrote the foreword and
enormous written a couple of great books
and he's Jewish and he read some of what
I'd written and he took me to task for
making the God of the Old Testament,
you know,
from a Christian perspective
too harsh and unforgiving.
And I rewrote a fair bit of it because
of his criticism and because of what I've
learned doing these lectures,
it's like it's not exactly right,
you know?
I mean what happens in the Old
Testament is if you screw up,
especially if you know you do and you
decide that you're not going to do
anything about it,
so it's conscious and deliberate,
then look the hell out.
You are in serious trouble.
And I actually think that's
also psychologically accurate.
One of the things young pointed out,
and this has always struck me,
was that if you don't
know what you're doing,
this is actually in the
gospel of Thomas as well.
Interestingly enough is one
of the Gods Gnostic Gospels,
Christ tells his followers something
like if you make a mistake and you don't
know what you're doing,
then you'll be forgiven for it.
But if you make a mistake knowing what
you're doing and you do it anyways,
then like good luck to you and,
and I,
and I think that's,
I think that's,
that's psychologically accurate.
Yes.
One of the things that's very interesting
about the judgemental God in the Old
Testament,
however,
is that he can be bargained with.
And even if you make mistakes,
especially if you're unconscious of them,
if you haven't learned yet,
let's say,
then you always have the opportunity
to return to the proper path.
And that's,
people get cynical about
that cause there's,
you know,
this mostly Christian idea that you
could live a terribly sinful life,
but if you repented on your death bed,
it's like heaven for you.
And it's like,
oh that's,
that sounds like a great deal.
Right?
It's like you can do whatever the hell
you want until just before you die.
Of course you might not know when that is.
So that's a problem.
You,
then you can just say,
well,
I'm sorry.
And you know,
everything's forgiven.
But the problem with being cynical
about that sort of thing is that it's no
trivial matter to repent,
you know?
Because to repent means a figure out what
you actually did and the worst things
that you did,
the more horrible it is to figure it out.
It's no joke,
right?
And there's no genuine repentance without
understanding of the depth of your
depravity.
And so if you lived to particularly
reprehensible life and you come to
understand it,
I think that in and of
itself could kill you.
You know,
it's a terrible thing to wake
up and see what you've done.
If what you've done is truly terrible.